d'iran je vous remercie
au nom de dieu le clément le
miséricordieux
louange à dieu dieu des mondes que ça
paie sa bénédiction soient sur mohamed
et sa maison ses compagnes monsieur le
président permettez moi d'en blesser
mais félicitations au président de
l'assemblée générale à l'occasion de son
élection la 66e session de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu mesdames et messieurs
l'iran est une terre de culture de
civilisation de savoir de spiritualité
de percer dans independence le pape
iranien et monothéistes est patriote son
identité est unique il aime explorer le
monde des centaines d'années durant
notre nation à préserver son droit à
l'autodétermination
sandra la liberté face à
l'hégémonie a fait du pays le plus
progressiste en matière de système
politique fondé sur les élections dans
toute l'asie de l'ouest la révolution
islamique en effet été un bond en avant
en matière de réalisation des idéaux
nationaux islamique des iraniens y
compris la liberté l'indépendance la
démocratie religieuse en tant que
président élu du grand peuple d'iran je
suis honoré de le représenter et de
livrer au monde un message de
rationalité de justice de liberté les
trois principes fondamentaux qui
régissent la vie de l'homme
d'aujourd'hui cependant ces trois
principes que partagent les religion
d'abraham non pas ne peuvent pas
atteindre leurs objectifs sans
spiritualité la liberté et la justice
sont deux termes sacré innocent trop
vaste pour être définies y est ils sont
complexes s'agissant de leurs pratiques
la liberté signifie le droit de penser
de décider d'agir
pour tous les êtres humains
la paix la sécurité durable sont liées à
l'administration de la justice est en
substance les prophètes divins ont vu le
jour de sorte que les peuples puissent
exil justice exercer leur droit à la
justice de la liberté ne sont possibles
que lorsque les droits de toutes les
nations sont respectées de fait toute
violation des droits des nations
ne fera que menacer la paix et la
sécurité mondiales
mesdames et messieurs cette année
deux scènes sont entrés dans les livres
d'histoire la première remonte au 6
janvier lorsque le congrès des états
unis a été attaqué par la population la
seconde
est celle de ce peuple afghan qui
étaient jetés des avions américains en
août
du capitole jusqu'à kaboul un message on
ne peut plus clair a été envoyé au monde
le système hégémonique des états unis
est dénué de toute crédibilité
à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur du pays
ce que nous voyons dans notre région
aujourd'hui nous prouve que non
seulement l'hégémonie mais aussi l'idée
même de l'hégémonie ainsi que ce projet
visant à imposer une identité
occidentale ont misérablement échoué
la quête e et g monique a entraîné un
bain de sang l'instabilité la défaite et
puis la fuite
aujourd'hui les états unis ne quitte pas
l'irak et l'afghanistan mais en sont
expulsés dans le même temps ce sont les
peuple opprimé de palestine de syrie en
passant par le yémen l'afghanistan
ainsi même que les contribuables
américains qui doivent payer ce manque
de rationalité
aujourd'hui le monde n'a cure de du
slogan l'amérique avant tout l'amérique
est de retour si la rationalité
l'emportent dans les esprits des
décideurs politiques ils doivent
comprendre que la persévérance des
nations est plus forte que la force des
plus puissants au cours de la décennie
écoulée les etats unis
se sont fourvoyés dans l'idée de
modifier leurs façons de faire la guerre
plutôt que de modifier leur façon de
vivre
un chemin erroné ne peut pas porter ses
fruits même si longchamp méthode les
sanctions sont la nouvelle arme de
guerre des états unis face aux nations
du monde les sanctions imposées à l'iran
n'ont pas débuté avec le programme
nucléaire de mon pays elle remonte avant
même à la révolution islamique à 1951
date à laquelle la nationalisation du
pétrole
étaient en cours en iran qui devait
amener un coup d'état militaire soutenu
par les américains et les britanniques
contre le gouvernement iranien de
l'époque qui avait été élu par le peuple
les sanctions notamment les sanctions
dans le secteur médical
en pleine pandémie le colis de 19 sont
un crime contre l'humanité le saint
coran considère la destruction de la
nature et de l'humanité comme une des
principales caractéristiques des tyrans
la république islamique d'iran
estime que toute sanction et les
restrictions les perturbations liées aux
sanctions dans le domaine de la santé de
l'environnement sont des questions
humanitaires et doivent être
interdites qui plus est au nom de la
nation iranienne et des millions de
réfugiés qu'accueil mon pays
j'aimerais condamné le maintien des
sanctions américaines il légal notamment
dans le secteur humanitaire
j'exige que ce crime organisé contre
l'humanité soit considéré comme un
symbole une réalité de ce que l'on
appelle les droits humains à
l'américaine bien que la république
islamique d'iran est d'entrée de jeu
souhaité acheter importer des vaccins
contre la copie de 19 en provenance de
sources internationales fiable
il s'est confronté à des sanctions
médical inhumaine
par conséquent dès le début
nous sommes lancés dans la production
durable de vaccins nationaux
outre les technologies satellites et
nucléaire pacifique l'iran est la plaque
tournante dans la région en matière
médicale nombre de médecins de
scientifiques iraniens tels cas vie
sénat brille dans l'histoire de
l'humanité le savoir qui bénéficie à
l'humanité ne saurait être sans que
donnez
nous avons nous même réussi à produire
du combustible pour le réacteur de
recherche de téhéran qui permet de
produire des médicaments
radiopharmaceutiques pour plus d'un
million de victimes du cancer en iran
nous avons aussi réalisé des progrès
remarquables dans le domaine de la
biotechnologie des cellules souches en
dépit de toutes les sanctions imposées
aujourd'hui en dépit des sanctions
qui touchent aux droits humains nous
sommes devenus un fabricant de vaccins
contre la copie 19 la coopération entre
les pays du monde dans le domaine de la
santé en particulier dans le domaine des
vaccins
signifie soutenir l'esprit d'humanité la
politique fondée sur la dignité
d'humanité dans les relations
internationales la chorale à virus est
un coup de semonce pour le monde nous
rappelant que la sécurité des êtres
humains et est interdépendante les
crises qui touchent les sociétés
humaines la violence la pauvreté le
chômage la corruption morale et
économique
l'effondrement des valeurs familiales
les guerres régionales le terrorisme
organisé et les crises environnementales
sont la résultante de l'abandon des
principes mêmes de rationalité de
justice et de liberté
mesdames et messieurs
les pensées stratégiques de la
république islamique d'iran sont ancrés
dans les idéaux de l'architecte de la
révolution islamique feu l'imam khomeiny
que son âme repose en paix ainsi que
dans les concepts authentique du
véritable islam la rationalité la
prudence la pondération
l ont amené à la résistance dans les
intérêts dans l'intérêt de notre pays
parler de droits des nations sans
évoquer les obligations des
gouvernements ne permet pas de réaliser
les droits l'indépendance de la nation
et sa liberté la révolution islamique
soutient ce type de liberté et donc fait
barrage à l'extrémisme telle est la
nature même de la république islamique
d'iran qui fait le bien pour tous et
toutes la république islamique d'iran
est source d'inspiration le pouvoir qui
en émane est donc source de sécurité ce
modèle sécuritaire de la république
d'iran se fonde sur la création de
mécanismes atra régionaux au travers
d'une diplomatie libre de toute
ingérence extérieure
nous nous sommes toujours efforcés de
préserver la stabilité l'intégrité
territoriale de tous les pays de la
région si ce n'était pas grâce au
pouvoir et rôle de l'iran aux côtés des
gouvernements des peuples de syrie et
d'irak et grâce aux efforts des
intéressés des martyrs abou madi alwan
10 et le général qasem soleimani et bien
aujourd'hui l'oeil elle serait ta
voisins méditerranéens de l'europe est
bien entendu l'oeil elle ne sera pas la
dernière vague d'extrémisme les
nouvelles tentatives de créer des
divisions digne de la guerre froide
n'aideront pas à améliorer la sécurité
des populations en isolant les pays
indépendants
l'arbitraire n'est pas le moyen de
régler le terrorisme le terrorisme tire
ses racines dans les crises telles que
la crise identitaire où la crise
économique le fait que la vie moderne
est aujourd'hui dénué de toute
spiritualité de sens le fait que la
pauvreté la discrimination et oppression
se propage tout cela fait le lit du
terrorisme la croissance du terrorisme
autochtones à l'ouest attestent de cette
vérité amère plus amer encore et
l'emploi du terrorisme en tant qu
instrument de politique étrangère car on
ne peut pas lutter contre le terrorisme
parle deux poids deux mesures vous ne
pouvez pas créer un groupe terroriste
elle que le yale à un endroit et
prétendre lutter contre lui ailleurs
après avoir cherché la grâce de dieu
tout puissant la solution aux
affrontements et au conflit dans notre
régie région réside dans ce qui suit
faire en sorte que les nations puissent
prendre en main leur destin en recourant
aux urnes pour que ceux ci soient
possibles deux prérequis fondamentaux
sont nécessaires premièrement faire
cesser les agressions venus de
l'extérieur et l'occupation et
deuxièmement une coopération sincère des
gouvernements pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
la présence militaire des etats-unis en
syrie et en irak est le principal
obstacle à l'établissement de la
démocratie à la volonté des nations la
liberté ne trouve pas sa place dans le
fournissement des soldats provenant de
l'extérieur de la région
si un gouvernement inclusif veut
vraiment sûrs et la participation
efficace des groupes c'est nick aussi
c'est ce gouvernement inclusif
n'apparaît pas en afghanistan la
sécurité ne sera pas possible et tout
comme l'occupation le paternalisme est
vouée à l'échec la crise humanitaire au
yémen est des plus inquiétantes le monde
doit sortir du silence à ses crimes
contre l'humanité quelle est la solution
la solution consiste à mettre un terme
rapidement et sans condition à
l'agression yéménite ouvrant des voies
d'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire
facilitant la tenue de pourparlers
constructifs entre les groupes i mean it
le régime d'occupation sioniste est à
l'origine de la plus grande vague de
terrorisme d'état dont la seule visée
est de
tuer des femmes et des enfants à gaza et
en cisjordanie aujourd'hui un blocus à
grande échelle a transformé gaza en la
plus grande prison au monde ce que l'on
a appelé l'accord du siècle a échoué
tout comme tout autre accord imposé de
force aux palestiniens il n'y a qu'une
solution tenir un référendum
auquel participeraient tous les
palestiniens tout les palestiniens de
toutes religions et groupes ethniques
musulmans chrétiens juifs
cette solution a été avancée par le
guide suprême de la république islamique
durant il y à dire en date des années
et et consignées dans un document
officiel des nations unies monsieur le
président
aujourd'hui le monde tout entier y
compris les américains ont admis que le
projet visant à lutter contre le peuple
iranien qui s'est manifestée sous la
forme d'une violation du péage et c
était suivi par une politique de la
pression maximale à retrait arbitraire
d'un accord reconnu à l'international
cette tentative a été un échec
dix ans mais cette politique de la
tyrannie maximale perdure nous ne
voulons ni plus ni moins que ce qui nous
revient revient légitimement nous
exigeons le respect des règles
internationales toutes les parties
doivent respecter l'accord sur le
nucléaire et la résolution de l'onu dans
la pratique
15 rapport de l'eia ont attesté du
respect par l'iran de ses engagements en
revanche les états unis ne se sont pas
encore acquittées de leurs obligations à
savoir lever les sanctions
les états unis ont empiété sur la corse
en sont retirées imposant davantage de
sanctions encore à mon peuple les etats
unis se sont fourvoyés en croyant qu'ils
pourraient nous plonger dans le
désespoir ou la dévastation notre
persévérance a porté ses fruits et
continuera de le faire
la résistance intelligente et dynamique
de la république islamique d'iran
découle de notre rationalité stratégique
nous ne faisons pas confiance aux
promesses du gouvernement américain
il est une politique stratégique de la
république islamique d'iran qui veut que
la production le stockage des armes
atomiques soit interdite sur la base du
décret religieux de son éminence le
guide suprême les armes nucléaires n'ont
pas leur place dans notre doctrine de la
défense et dans notre politique de
dissuasion la république islamique
estime que les pourparlers dont le but
ultime est la levée de toutes les
sanctions oppressives sont utiles nous
défendons
les droits les intérêts de notre peuple
et ce faisant l'iran souhaite une
coopération économique et politique à
grande échelle une convergence de vue
avec le reste du monde je souhaite
interagir avec tous les pays du monde en
particulier avec nos voisins
dont je serre la main chaleureusement
une ère nouvelle a débuté la république
islamique d'iran est prête à apporter sa
pierre à l'édifice d'un monde meilleur
un monde
débordant de rationalité de justice de
liberté de moralité et de spiritualité
je vous remercie toutes et tous pour
votre attention que la paix et la
miséricorde d'allah soit avec vous
au nom de l'assemblée générale je
remercie le président de la république
islamique d'iran pour l'allocution qu'il
vient de prononcer je donne à présent la
parole au représentant du chili qui
introduirait l'allocution de son chef
d'état
monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire général excellence j'ai
l'honneur
d'introduire
l'allocution de son excellence le
président de la république du chili
sebastian pinera et